et on avait une relation sexuelle pour la première fois.
Maintenant, on se marie,
et on arrête d'avoir des relations sexuelles avec les autres.
Le fait est que la monogamie n'avait rien à voir avec l'amour.
Les hommes comptaient sur la fidélité des femmes
pour savoir de qui étaient les enfants,
et qui aura la vache lorsque je mourrai.
Maintenant, tout le monde veut savoir
quel pourcentage de personnes trompent.
On m'a posé cette question depuis mon arrivée à cette conférence.
(Rires)
Cela s'applique à vous.
Mais la définition de l'infidélité continue de s'étendre :
messages coquins, regarder du porno,
rester secrètement actif sur des applications de rencontre.
Puisqu'il n'y a pas de définition acceptée universellement
de ce qui constitue une infidélité,
les estimations varient largement entre 26% et 75%.
Mais, au-delà de ça, nous sommes des contradictions ambulantes.
95% d'entre nous disent que c'est terriblement mal
que notre partenaire mente au sujet d'une aventure,
mais environ autant d'entre nous diront
que c'est exactement ce que nous ferions si nous en avions une.
(Rires)
J'aime cette définition de ce qu'est une liaison --
elle réunit trois éléments-clés :
une relation secrète, qui est la structure fondamentale d'une liaison ;
une connexion émotionnelle, à un degré ou à un autre ;
et une alchimie sexuelle.
Alchimie est ici le mot-clé
car le frisson érotique est tel que le baiser qu'on imagine donner,
peut être aussi puissant et enchanteur
que des heures à faire l'amour.
Comme l'a dit Marcel Proust :
c'est notre imagination qui est responsable de l'amour,
pas l'autre personne.
Il n'a jamais été simple de tromper,
et il n'a jamais été plus difficile de garder un secret.
L'infidélité n'a jamais fait autant de ravages psychologiques.
Quand le mariage était une entreprise économique,
l'infidélité menaçait notre sécurité économique.
Mais maintenant que le mariage est un arrangement romantique,
l'infidélité menace notre sécurité émotionnelle.
C'est ironique, avant, on se tournait vers l'adultère --
c'était l'endroit où on cherchait l'amour pur.
Mais maintenant qu'on cherche l'amour dans le mariage,
l'adultère le détruit.
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui, l'adultère blesse de trois façons.
On a un idéal romantique dans lequel on va vers l'autre
pour combler une liste de besoins sans fin :
être mon meilleur amant, mon meilleur ami,
le meilleur parent, un confident en qui j'ai confiance,
mon compagnon émotionnel, mon égal intellectuel.
Et je le suis : je suis choisi, je suis unique,
je suis indispensable, je suis irremplaçable,
Je suis le seul et unique.
Et l'infidélité me dit que je ne le suis pas.
C'est la trahison ultime.
L'infidélité bouleverse la grande ambition de l'amour.
Mais si, à travers l'histoire, l'infidélité a toujours été douloureuse,
aujourd'hui, elle est souvent traumatisante
car elle menace notre idée sur nous-même.
Mon patient Fernando est tourmenté.
Il dit : « Je pensais connaitre ma vie.
Je pensais te connaitre, nous connaitre en tant que couple,
savoir qui j'étais.
Maintenant je doute de tout. »
L'infidélité -- une violation de la confiance, une crise identitaire.
« Pourrai-je jamais te refaire confiance ? »
« Pourrai-je refaire confiance à quiconque ? »
Et c'est aussi ce que ma patiente Heather me dit,
quand elle me parle de son histoire avec Nick.
Mariés, deux enfants.
Nick vient de partir en voyage d'affaires,
Heather joue avec les garçons sur son iPad
quand elle voit apparaitre un message à l'écran :
« J'ai hâte de te voir ».
Bizarre, pense-t-elle, on vient juste de se voir.
Puis un autre message :
« J'ai hâte de te tenir dans mes bras ».
Et Heather réalise
qu'ils ne sont pas pour elle.
Elle me dit aussi que son père avait des liaisons,
mais que sa mère avait trouvé un ticket dans sa poche
et un peu de rouge à lèvres sur son col.
Heather continue à creuser,
et trouve des centaines de messages,
de photos échangées, de désirs exprimés.
Les détails frappants de la liaison de Nick depuis 2 ans
se révèlent devant elle en temps réel.
Ça m'a fait pensé :
les liaisons à l'ère du numérique c'est une mort à petit feu.
Nous faisons également face à un autre paradoxe de nos jours.
A cause de cet idéal romantique,
on compte sur la fidélité de notre partenaire
avec une ferveur unique.
Mais on n'a jamais été plus enclins au vagabondage,
pas parce qu'on a de nouveaux désirs,
mais parce qu'on vit dans une ère
où on se sent autorisé à poursuivre nos désirs,
parce que c'est la culture où je mérite d'être heureux.
Et si, avant, on divorçait parce qu'on était malheureux,
aujourd'hui, on divorce parce qu'on pourrait être plus heureux.
Et si le divorce était une honte,
aujourd'hui, choisir de rester lorsqu'on peut partir
est la nouvelle honte.
Heather ne peut pas parler à ses amis,
car elle a peur d'être jugée pour aimer toujours Nick,
et où qu'elle aille, elle reçoit le même conseil :
quitte-le. Laisse le chien sur le trottoir.
Et si la situation était inversée, Nick serait dans la même position.
Rester est la nouvelle honte.
Donc si on peut divorcer,
pourquoi a-t-on toujours des liaisons ?
La supposition classique est que si on trompe,
soit il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas dans votre relation ou chez vous.
Ce n'est pas possible que des millions de personnes soient pathologiques.
La logique est : si vous avez tout ce qu'il vous faut à la maison,
vous n'avez pas besoin d'aller voir ailleurs,
en considérant que le mariage parfait existe
et qu'il nous inocule de l'envie de vagabonder.
Mais et si la passion avait une durée de vie limitée ?
Et s'il y avait des choses que même une bonne relation
ne peut jamais fournir ?
Si même les gens heureux trompent,
de quoi s'agit-il ?
La vaste majorité des personnes avec lesquelles je travaille
ne sont pas du tout des coureurs de jupons chroniques.
Ce sont souvent des personnes qui croient profondément en la monogamie,
au moins pour leur partenaire.
Mais ils se retrouvent au cœur d'un conflit
opposant leurs valeurs et leur comportement.
Ce sont souvent des gens qui ont été fidèles durant des dizaines d'années,
mais un jour ils franchissent la limite
qu'ils pensaient ne jamais franchir,
et ce au risque de tout perdre.
Mais pour une lueur de quoi ?
Les liaisons sont un acte de trahison,
et elles sont aussi une expression de désir et de perte.
A la source d'une liaison, on trouve souvent
le désir et l'aspiration à une connexion émotionnelle,
à la nouveauté, la liberté, l'autonomie, l'intensité sexuelle,
un souhait de récupérer des partis perdues de nous-mêmes
ou une tentative de ramener la vitalité face à la perte et la tragédie.
Je pense à une autre de mes patientes, Priya,
qui est mariée et heureuse en ménage,
aime son mari,
et ne voudrait jamais le blesser.
Mais elle me dit également
qu'elle a toujours fait ce qu'on attendait d'elle :
bonne fille, bonne femme, bonne mère,
prenant soin de ses parents immigrés.
Priya est tombée amoureuse de l'arboriste qui a enlevé un arbre de son jardin
après l'ouragan Sandy.
Avec son camion et ses tatouages, il est son opposé.
Mais à 47 ans, la liaison de Priya relève de l'adolescence qu'elle n'a jamais eue.
Pour moi, son histoire met en valeur
le fait que lorsqu'on cherche le regard de quelqu'un d'autre,
on ne s'éloigne pas toujours de son partenaire,
mais de la personne qu'on est devenu.
Et ce n'est pas tant qu'on cherche quelqu'un d'autre,
mais qu'on cherche un autre soi.
A travers le monde,
il y a ce mot que les gens qui ont des liaisons me disent toujours.
Ils se sentent en vie.
Et ils me racontent souvent des histoire récentes d'une perte --
d'un parent qui est mort,
d'un ami parti trop tôt,
de mauvaises nouvelles chez le médecin.
La mort et la mortalité vivent souvent dans l'ombre d'une liaison,
parce qu'elles soulèvent ces questions.
Est-ce que c'est tout ? Y a-t-il plus ?
Vais-je continuer ainsi pendant 25 ans ?
Sentirai-je à nouveau ça ?
Et ça m'a menée à penser que peut-être ces questions
sont celles qui poussent les gens à franchir la limite,
que certaines liaisons sont une tentative de revanche sur la mort intérieure,
un antidote à la mort.
Et contrairement à ce que vous pensez peut-être
les liaisons relèvent beaucoup moins de sexe mais plutôt de désir :
un désir d'attention, un désir de se sentir spécial,
un désir de se sentir important.
Et la structure-même d'une liaison,
le fait que vous ne pouvez jamais avoir votre amant,
vous laisse désirer.
C'est, en soi, une machine à désir,
parce que le côté incomplet, l'ambigüité,
vous laisse désirer ce que vous ne pouvez avoir.
Certains d'entre vous pensent probablement
que les liaisons n'arrivent pas dans les relations libres,
mais si.
Tout d'abord, la conversation sur la monogamie n'est pas la même
que la conversation sur l'infidélité.
Mais le fait qu'il semble que même lorsqu'on a
la liberté d'avoir d'autres partenaires sexuels,
on semble toujours attirés par le pouvoir de l'interdit,
que si on fait ce qu'on n'est pas censés faire,
alors on a l'impression de faire ce qu'on veut vraiment faire.
Et j'ai aussi dit à nombre de mes patients
que s'ils pouvaient amener dans leurs relations
un dixième de l'audace, de l'imagination et de la verve
qu'ils mettent dans leurs liaisons,
ils n'auraient probablement jamais besoin de me voir.
(Rires)
Comment guérir d'une liaison ?
Le désir est profond.
La trahison est profonde.
Mais c'est guérissable.
Et certaines liaisons sonnent le glas
de relations qui étaient déjà en train de dépérir.
Mais d'autre nous propulserons vers de nouvelles possibilités.
Le fait est que la majorité des couples
ayant connu des liaisons restent ensemble.
Mais certains d'entre eux vont surtout survivre,
et d'autres seront vraiment capables de transformer une crise en opportunité.
Ils seront capable de transformer ceci en une expérience productive.
Et je pense que c'est encore plus vrai pour le partenaire trompé,
qui dira souvent :
« Tu penses que je ne voulais pas plus ?
Mais je ne suis pas celui qui l'a fait. »
Mais maintenant que la liaison est révélée,
eux aussi peuvent demander plus
et ils n'ont plus à maintenir le status quo
qui ne fonctionnaient peut-être pas pour eux non plus.
J'ai remarqué que de nombreux couples,
à la suite d'une liaison,
à cause de ce nouveau désordre qui pourrait mener à un nouvel ordre,
auront des conversations d'une profondeur, d'une honnêteté et d'une ouverture
qu'ils n'avaient pas eues depuis des dizaines d'années.
Et les partenaires qui étaient sexuellement indifférents
s'avèrent soudainement être voraces et plein de désirs,
et ils ne avent pas d'où ça provient.
Quelque chose lié à la peur de la perte ravivera le désir
et fera la place à un nouveau genre de vérité.
Quand une liaison est révélée,
quelles sont spécifiquement certaines des choses que les couples peuvent faire ?
On sait des traumatismes que la guérison commence
quand le coupable reconnait qu'il a mal agit.
Pour le partenaire qui a eu une liaison,
pour Nick,
une chose est de mettre fin à cette liaison,
mais l'autre chose essentielle et importante est d'exprimer
la culpabilité et le remord d'avoir blessé sa femme.
La vérité est
que j'ai remarqué que de nombreuses personnes ayant des liaisons
peuvent se sentir terriblement coupables d'avoir blessé leur partenaire,
mais ne se sentent pas coupable de l'expérience de la liaison en elle-même.
Cette distinction est importante.
Nick doit être vigilant envers sa relation.
Il doit devenir, pour un temps, le protecteur des limites.
Il est de sa responsabilité d'en parler,
parce que s'il y pense,
il peut libérer Heather de l'obsession,
et s'assurer que la liaison n'est pas oubliée,
ce qui, en sois, commence à restaurer la confiance.
Mais pour Heather,
ou les partenaires trompés,
il est essentiel de faire des choses restaure l'estime de soi,
s'entourer d'amour et d'amis, faire des activités
qui réinstaurent la joie, le sens et l'identité.
Mais encore plus important,
c'est de contrôler la curiosité qui pousse à chercher des détails sordides --
Où étais-tu ? Où l'avez-vous fait ?
Combien de fois ? Est-elle meilleure que moi au lit ? --
des questions qui n'infligent que plus de douleur,
et vous tiennent réveillés.
Au lieu de cela, passez à ce que j'appelle les questions d'investigation,
celles qui cherchent le sens et les motivations --
Que signifiait cette liaison pour toi ?
Qu'as-tu pu y exprimer ou y expérimenter
que tu ne peux plus faire avec moi ?
Qu'est-ce que cela faisait de rentrer à la maison ?
Qu'apprécies-tu chez nous ?
Es-tu content que ce soit fini ?
Chaque liaison va redéfinir une relation
et chaque couple déterminera
l'héritage qu'aura cette liaison.
Mais il y aura toujours des liaisons, elles ne vont pas disparaitre.
Et les dilemmes de l'amour et du désir,
ne donnent pas de réponses simples : noir ou blanc, bon ou mauvais,
victime et malfaiteur.
La trahison existe sous de nombreuses formes dans une relation.
Nous pouvons trahir notre partenaire de nombreuses façons :
avec du mépris, de la négligence,
de l'indifférence, de la violence.
La trahison sexuelle n'est qu'une façon de blesser un partenaire.
En d'autres mots, la victime dans une liaison
n'est pas toujours la victime dans le mariage.
Vous m'avez écoutée
et je sais ce que vous pensez :
elle a un accent français, elle doit être pro-liaisons.
(Rires)
Vous avez tort.
Je ne suis pas française.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Et je ne suis pas pro-liaisons.
Mais parce que je pense que l'on peut tirer du bon d'une liaison,
on m'a souvent posé cette question très étrange :
Recommanderais-je une liaison ?
Je ne recommanderais pas plus que vous ayez une liaison
que je ne vous recommanderais d'avoir un cancer,
et pourtant nous savons que les gens qui ont été malades
parlent souvent de comment leur maladie leur a ouvert de nouvelles perspectives.
La question qu'on m'a le plus posée depuis que je suis arrivée à cette conférence
et que j'ai dit que je parlerai d'infidélité, c'était : pour ou contre ?
J'ai dit : « Oui. »
(Rires)
Je vois les liaisons de deux façons :
la douleur et la trahison d'un côté,
la croissance et la découverte de soi d'un autre côté --
ce que cela t'a fait, et ce que cela signifiait pour moi.
Donc quand un couple vient me voir après une liaison
qui a été révélée,
je leur dis souvent cela :
De nos jours dans l'Ouest,
la plupart d'entre nous auront deux ou trois relations
ou mariages,
et certains d'entre nous le vivront avec la même personne.
Votre premier mariage est terminé.
Voudriez-vous en créer un deuxième ensemble ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)